the view the ladies of the view have an
important lesson to teach you about the
power of the
AR-15 and its uses in hunting I would
love to see an assault weapons ban like
President Reagan I don't believe there a
sport or hunting um uh instrument it's
like shooting fish in a bucket but
that's my but also if you shoot with an
AR-15 let's say you shoot a deer you
can't eat it because you basically
demolish in addition to that but the
Hunt is about an actual difficult
process not massacring bodies of any
kind but my point is I'd love to see
that Joy bear seems to be confusing an
AR-15 with a rocket launcher she she
seems to be confusing an AR-15 with a
landmine that would just explode the
deer ironically she's somewhat correct
in what she said she said if you shoot a
deer with an AR-15 you won't be able to
eat it and that might be true because
the deer might get away because the
AR-15 round the 223 is probably too weak
to at least to humanely hunt deer and
actually certain places have
restrictions on the AR15 for hunting
deer for precisely that reason not
because it's going to explode the deer
not because it's I don't know it's like
a heat seeking missile that just
explodes and splatters venison all over
the place but because it's it's a little
weak it's lot weaker than these people
think they have no idea which gets to
what I think is beneath a lot of the
political dysfunction that we have right
now which is not just evil ideology or
uh the tolerance and encouragement of
vice and sin all of which contribute to
our political
problems but the problem of blle
ignorance the fact that people are just
so
casually happily indiff
to knowledge and the truth and
skill it's astounding you
can't you can't run a society on bad
ideology it's not going to work out in
the end you also can't just run a
society on ideology you need to possess
some degree of technical knowledge and
competence to run a society it's not
enough just to read Carl Marx or just to
read Edmund Burke or Aristotle for that
matter you also need to know how to how
to do plumbing you also need to know how
to grow food you also need to know how
to perform the basic functions of a
society and a society that doesn't know
how guns work a society that doesn't
know how human beings relate to animals
certainly as it regards food production
that Society is is not going to do
well and you add on top of that bizarre
ideologies well I guess actually the the
the blle ignorance is a consequence of
of the ideological age which tells
people that when they go to school they
don't need to learn
anything real or substantive they can
just
read a bunch of theories disconnected
from reality they can just major in
gender studies to use an offs sited
example and that will prepare them for
life it will not do so right now go to
EK pure.com use code nolles did you know
that the flu season costs Americans over
11 billion billion with a B dollars
every year kids get sick they miss
school parents stay home from work to
take care of their kids then they get
sick themselves that's why we have
enviral cleanse in our office we have
right now a wonderful offer for our
listeners 30% off make sure to act fast
since the sale is ending soon enviral
cleans is an inhome air purifying unit
proven to capture and Destroy flu
viruses bacteria toxins mold and
allergens from your home and viroc
cleanse technology is so powerful it was
chosen to purify the air systems on
board Navy ships and Subs enviral
cleanse helps keep our service men and
women healthier and it can help you and
your family stay healthier too enviral
cleanse is the only home air purifier
that promises Better Health by keeping
your home free of Cold and Flu viruses
go to EK pure.com use code NES canes for
33 % off your enviral cleanse home air
purification unit EK pure.com promo code
NES kwes for
330% off here is the classic New Yorker
taking umbrage at the fact that some guy
was tearing down posters of the missing
hostages who were taken by Hamas I'm
telling
you Jewish he's not Jewish I don't know
if he is not doesn't matter
USA New York City you don't have right
to touch this a free country you can
wave your Palestine flag and say death
to the Jews or America whatever you want
but we can put a signs okay then don't
rip that down you are doing something
you're offending
us yeah you are when you throw that on
the floor you're littering the city in a
minute I'm going to litter the floor
with you move the you have proof they're
not kidnapped no so shut the
up I know that's you
want maybe it's because I'm a New Yorker
myself but this kind of reaction I love
it now you know what the
Nerds and the Eggheads and the
ideologues are going to say even on the
right they're going to say um uh
actually uh that man is threatening that
other man's free speech he's actually we
should be able to have a reasonable
debate in the free Marketplace of ideas
and you should yeah shut up nerd I like
that guy's argument more when he goes
yeah you're offending me and I don't
like that so you stop ripping those
signs down and on top of offending all
of us you're littering and in a minute
I'm goingon to litter your face on the
floor if you don't put it back and get
out of here I love it that's a beautiful
thing that's cancel culture that's the
good kind of cancel culture this goes so
much deeper than the war in the Middle
East put the war in the Middle East put
the horrific terror attack put the
terrible situation where hostages are
still being held by Hamas put all of
those particular circumstances aside for
a
second this is about the right of
communities to set and enforce their own
standards the best thing that guy said
there was he goes you're offending us
mother effer and so many conservatives
are going to say well you know um I I
don't have an obligation to respect your
feelings and actually I could say
whatever I want without consequences
because we need to just have debates all
the time no that's not really how
political Society works
works we have the right to sensibilities
we have the right to preferences not
just individual preferences and
sensibilities but communal preferences
and sensibilities we have the right to
standards and
behavior and that guy that New York
classic New Yorker just coming out said
keep it up watch one more time I'm going
to show you what I'm going to do that is
actually the right attitude it reminds
me of that base level of conservatism
that even we think of New York is being
very left-wing there is a base level of
conservatism to a lot of New
Yorkers you see it right
now in in New York immigration is
threatening the whole city because as
this flood of migrants comes across as
we're going to take in what 3 four
million illegal immigrants this year a
lot of them are going to New York and
even the liberal Democrats are saying
this is a big threat to the whole city
there was a poll that just came out a
large and growing majority of New
Yorkers say that the illegal immigrants
pose a quote serious
problem almost 60% agree with the mayor
liberal Democrat mayor Eric Adams who
says that the migrants could quote
destroy New York City this is according
to a Sienna College
poll and this shouldn't be all that
shocking one New Yorkers have a base
level of conservatism largely because of
foulmouthed
Italians but
two immigration was always a bipartisan
issue it it's only become
hyperarcs saying that we need no limits
on immigration whatsoever we need
totally unrestricted legal immigration
and frankly we need totally unrestricted
illegal immigration too and the
Republicans saying well actually the
best the Republicans could muster was
hey stop that illegal immigration but we
can still take millions and millions
more legal IM immigrants but you still
have that problem of assimilation so now
things are finally getting back to
normal back in the 1990s Bill Clinton
was at least he talked very tough on
illegal immigration so this is obviously
terrible but Republicans and Democrats
agreed and then became a partisan
ideological issue for a while and as
long as the the consequences of mass
migration were only being felt in those
border towns only in those awful red
States the Democrats didn't care now
that the ille immigrants are being sent
by people like Governor Abbott of Texas
or governor disantis of Florida being
sent to Martha's Vineyard being sent to
New York City being sent to Chicago
being sent to rth Beach Delaware now all
of a sudden the majority of everyone is
agreeing oh wow this pose is a serious
problem of
course of course this actually I know we
consider immigration now to be a really
hot button issue that no one wants to
touch there has all for most of American
History been broad bipartisan consensus
on how too much migration is a very bad
thing and it seems that that consensus
is coming back again boy what a great
clip that was huh I know I agree I'm
with you if you want more great content
you've got to ring the bell subscribe to
the Michael YouTube channel we'll see
you next time